how has the feminist movement of the
last few decades gone for you I mean
we've seen families disappear um 150
years ago the average woman had seven
kids 85% of people were married we're
more depressed than ever before we're on
anti-depressants um women women over the
age of 45 are the least happy
demographic again I've said this before
marriage isn't marriage anymore the
average marriage is seven years we have
things like no fault divorce sleep if
you're unhappy so what does that mean
marriage is a marriage equ some Happ Mar
about Duty and that this is the problem
we have with women like women men tend
to be better people than us yeah they
really do they tend to they they tend to
do the right thing